Let's can some pumpkin puree.
I'm using sugar pie pumpkins that I grew in my garden.
I highly recommend getting sugar pie pumpkins.
Don't use Jack o lantern pumpkins.
The taste is just not the same cause these have a higher sugar content.
Now this is technically not USDA recommended.
Do rebel can here. So if that's not your thing,
that's fine. Just don't do this.
You're gonna start by cutting the pumpkins in half
and scooping out the seeds.
I'm just gonna pop these in the oven at 400 for about 45 to an hour.
Just depends on the temperature of your oven
and how fast it gets things done.
Once they're done, they're gonna be nice and soft.
Should be able to stick a knife through them.
Peel off the skins. It's a bit tedious.
You might have to use your fingers.
Add the cooked pumpkin to a pot or a bowl.
And I just use my immersion blender
till you get it to this nice puree consistency.
Lateral into jars
and I do smack it around a little bit to get it to settle more.
We're gonna have 1 inch head space.
Wipe your rims with vinegar using my 4 jars.
Lids for these bands go on finger tight
and then I just set up my canner.
I do put vinegar in my canner to help with mineral deposits.
Since this only made two pints,
I also added in some black beans.
Process for 75 minutes. Be Careful to open your canner,
because I did get myself a nice steam burn.
So then I let them sit a little bit,
and I pull them out of the canner
and then let them sit for 24 hours.
And then I will take the bands off and then you are done.